[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al nuevo episodio
de boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión
nos lleva a caracas la capital de
venezuela país que atraviesa una
compleja situación económica social y
política los 22 años de la llegada del
modelo socialista impuesto por hugo
chávez este proyecto del socialismo del
siglo 21 del difunto presidente chávez
prometió eliminar las desigualdades pero
en la actualidad el sistema económico y
los proyectos construidos bajo este
modelo no lograron su objetivo la caída
de los precios del petróleo y las
sanciones internacionales han empeorado
la situación las consecuencias una grave
crisis económica y social que afecta a
todos los ciudadanos por igual sin
distinción el actual mandatario nicolás
maduro sucesor de chávez mantuvo su
legado y hoy los venezolanos sufren por
los altos costos de los alimentos y el
deterioro de los salarios se calcula que
al día de hoy la pobreza se ubica en un
95 por ciento nuestros periodistas
estuvieron en caracas una ciudad poco
abierta a las cámaras para hacer un
balance de la situación y conocer la
vida de algunos venezolanos
a las 40 minutos
a continuación desde caracas venezuela
presentamos el avance de las noticias
más importantes por radio miraflores la
voz
esta es una ciudad socialista que hizo
nuestro comandante chávez gracias a él y
gracias a philipp castro
estatal y nacida cuando pasaron al yo
por aquí verdad para el aeropuerto ellos
se fijaron en el terreno entonces fidel
castro les dio ese ideal que aquí fue
hace una gran ciudad o una urbanización
y eso fue en los 10 construidos en 2011
hugo chávez inauguró en estas montañas
su proyecto de ciudad socialista a una
hora de caracas ciudad caribia ofrecía
viviendas dignas y gratuitas a miles de
personas humildes o sin techo
una década después detrás de cada
ventana hay una familia que lucha contra
las adversidades de la vida cotidiana
maría vive en un apartamento con sus
hijos y nietos
mi mamá dice que es de ella pero yo
considero que esta casa es del gobierno
lo menos aquí muchas personas que le han
quitado su apartamento porque han
emigrado porque han sido mal comportado
entonces se los quitan
dónde
hace unos días una tragedia golpeó a la
familia édgar la expareja de geraldine
murió en perú a miles de kilómetros en
el periódico sale mafia matan volante en
estos lados
de que se balancea
desde perú uno de sus amigos le envió
este artículo a gerald y él me llamó por
teléfono y me dice hola me noto la norma
de sus hijos y yo sé lo que ha pasado y
él no esté el chamo perdió en la mañana
no me dice que discutió con alguien y en
la noche llegó un hombre verdad y le
disparó
édgar había huido de la grave crisis de
su país para encontrar trabajo y enviar
dinero a sus hijos
mariah está convencida de que nada de
esto habría ocurrido si chávez estuviera
vivo pertenece a la milicia bolivariana
un cuerpo de reservistas entrenados para
defender al gobierno de nicolás maduro
cuando haga un golpe en venezuela
tenemos que salir todos
hay que trabajar por bobina está
dispuesta a todo
bueno pero yo digo que no tiene
beneficios tharman inicio porque mamá al
contado del andar acá en la milicia y
55 24 años tiene en la milicia 55 años 5
o sea le han dado una caja anual yo lo
de disgusto
ellos son como una burla para mucha
gente
y el gobierno nos tiene a ellos como
para que sean el escudo
este es el hígado
cada vez más las diferencias políticas
son también generacionales
lo espacio en nuestra emisora
roberto dirige la radio de ciudad
caribia
cuando chávez
nació en ciudad caribia con el hombre y
la mujer nueva para seguir construyendo
el socialismo del siglo 21 esto está la
esencia principal de todo esto
la idea era desarrollar la industria y
el comercio local para que la ciudad
fuera autosuficiente
con la crisis el proyecto nunca prosperó
r
parte de los compañeros que están
sembrando por aquí y por allá va
tenemos un bloqueo desde hace rato
tenemos un ensañamiento de parte del
imperio norteamericano que
afectado
grandemente a la población
en todo el país el gobierno distribuye
regularmente paquetes de alimentos a
precios subvencionados los llamados
clubs
bueno está en disminuir esa masa plante
soy la primera comandando el coupage que
es una cuadrilla de paz un pueblo
organizado donde hombres y mujeres
hacemos el trabajo
político social
generalmente los clubs contienen
carbohidratos pero este día cada familia
recibe un pollo congelado y una
mortadela
una carnicería un pollo de hecho se
puede cortar
4 bolívar y aquí es como de pollo de
proteína y la bolsa sale en
4,10 o sea lo que eran 4 millones y es
un dólar
un dólar sale en un dólar
mientras en otro lado
mira lo que está diciendo en un dólar
nosotros damos soberano nosotros no
estamos eeuu nosotros estamos en
venezuela y pagamos en soberano
cada edificio tiene un proceso encargado
de distribuir los suministros a los
hogares
pero no excluimos no quiere decir que si
la persona es opositora ejemplo que si
era opositor nada más compositor aquí no
hay discusión
y
de nuestro comandante supremo un macho
del día
para ti
la alimentación es el nervio de la
crisis en venezuela en caracas en los
últimos años han surgido comedores
sociales en casi todos los barrios
y yo
qué es
desde mi equipo de ciento y pico de
niños hay aproximadamente a 22 niños que
tienen este alimento solamente en el día
cada día el comedor de la vega alimenta
gratuitamente a un centenar de niños
el gobierno nunca le ha gustado que
ninguna ong salga adelante cuando
comenzamos con los comedores hubo mucho
amedrentamiento hacia las madres cuando
ellas entraban al comedor le decían si
llevas al niño al comedor para que toda
la bolsa las cocineras son madres
voluntarias la comida proviene de
donaciones detrás de la iniciativa se
encuentra una ong cercana a la oposición
mucho que por la misma situación de la
inflación de todo eso no han podido
comprarlo los repuestos y entonces
quedan los carros los dejan hacia
abandonados en la calle en todas partes
los efectos de años de crisis y escasez
son visibles
[Música]
más claro
el gas esto es para comprar el gas
la moneda venezolana se devalúa
constantemente muy rápidamente los
billetes pierden todo su valor no tienes
hoy recorrido otra vez que reconozca
esta es la última carga porque yo empecé
bien ha dado un enfoque tengo tres
bombonas en el comedor vacía
no tenemos gas no hay agua se no cuando
quieren que haya agua
la electricidad de momento se va no
podemos tener una adquisición de
de nuestros alimentos como nosotros
desearíamos el venezolano no tiene
derecho a vivir como estamos viviendo al
igual que con los alimentos
subvencionados la distribución del gas
en los barrios se hace a través de un
bolsillo generalmente cercano el
gobierno
petare en lo alto de caracas fue durante
mucho tiempo un bastión chavista
holanda vegas es una militante de la
oposición por el amor blatter
no no podemos seguir en eso como sabrán
hola mi amor como esta de la brega en la
lucha estoy muy importante el
descontento se extiende cada vez más en
el barrio
este es mi ranchito sin embargo el
candidato de yolanda fracasó en las
últimas elecciones locales que ganaron
los chavistas fuertemente movilizados
pasa para acá para que tuvieran como yo
vivo aquí los todos vacíos no hay agua
el bañito
yolanda trabaja como empleada municipal
recibe una pensión de 7 bolívares menos
de 2 dólares al mes que hice yo con mi
pensión de esta semana de este mes y me
compré esta bolsita de completo y una
bolsita de leche de 120 gramos sabe en
las tiendas del barrio ahora los precios
se muestran en dólares las personas
mayores viven en la pobreza con un
sistema sanitario precario buenas tardes
cómo están
y ella se cayó
tuvieron que hacer una operación ella se
vio grave en esa operación de hecho le
habían dado por muerta y bueno y
y le dejaron lo que es la la tripa
afuera tras una colostomía de urgencia
avelina no puede permitirse otra
operación ni tampoco comprar una bolsa
intestino que me regalando un guante y
un favor el guante las tragedias son una
constante en la vida de avelina ha
perdido cuatro hijos tres fueron
asesinados por la violencia entre
pandillas otro por la policía este el
último que demandaron a ello muchacho
sano trabajador este fue su esposo que
murió cuando le dieron la noticia de que
ella estaba muerta
a la hora de comer solo tiene unas pocas
papas para hervir
sí porque para eso tiene que tener un
alimento balanceado y como y como te lo
come
por lo menos ya cómo es ella está mañana
con el comedor hasta mañana feliz de
verdad qué
unos y sufrir
pero era de mi esposo me poseerá
carlista
pero orgulloso de esto el gobierno que
tú lo tienes el aquí no te dan una ayuda
te das cuenta entonces no tenemos que
adorarlo como que si fuera un dios
porque hay un solo dios la sombra de
hugo chávez sigue planeando sobre
venezuela pero el país ha cambiado desde
2020 la dolarización no oficial
permitida por el gobierno le ha dado un
nuevo impulso a la economía en caracas
han reaparecido islotes de riqueza
edificios restaurantes o cafés chic no
somos la primera empresa en hacer café
en cápsulas
ya tenemos la oportunidad de poder
manejarnos una moneda extranjera y eso
genera por supuesto no solamente
confianza sino determinado oportunidad
de negocio
aquí un café vale de dos a tres dólares
el salario mensual de muchos venezolanos
son dos venezuelas esta es la realidad
de la mayoría del país
una burbuja
la brecha social que a raíz de todo esto
se ha enmarcado mucho más de lo
que no es la idea de socialismo
en esta economía enloquecida todo el
mundo lucha por salir adelante
son las 7 de la mañana geraldine de
ciudad caribia vende café en el
principal mercado mayorista de caracas
tendía hacia ese termo
[Música]
lo que es hermoso como 30 dólares al mes
los dominicos
[Música]
a pesar de la muerte de su expareja que
se había ido a probar suerte a perú
geraldine tiene un proyecto y miente
yo quisiera emigrar porque pienso que
aquí no hay futuro aquí por lo menos
mismo yo
no lo suficiente
casi 6 de los 30 millones de venezolanos
se han exiliado tanto los que se van
como los que se quedan no ven el final
de esta crisis que ha cambiado tantas
vidas
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a caracas recuerde que
si quiere ver este y otros episodios en
español puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom hasta pronto